[Music]
it was in this suit that Neil Armstrong
uttered those famous words 50 years ago
but in 2015 after nearly a decade in
storage its age had caught up with it
time is taking its toll and it's - the
layers you don't see conservators at the
Smithsonian National Air and Space
Museum recognized the importance of
saving the degrading piece of history
which they did by launching a
Kickstarter campaign called reboot the
suit the project received thousands of
public donations allowing conservators
to research document and preserve the
spacesuits condition and this week the
suit made its second debut when the
museum announced its conservation was
complete professor James Hansen is
Armstrong's official biographer I think
the story of Neil Armstrong I think that
the Smithsonian and its curators are
very wise in knowing that that's a
two-part story that needs to be told
as a result of this research Armstrong's
Apollo 11 suit will go on public display
at the Smithsonian for the first time in
13 years on the anniversary of its first
mission which will be July 16th Wow yeah
they raised how much money over five
hundred thousand dollars and they're
saying you know took a lot because they
have the special case that they have to
put the suit in to preserve it pretty
cool code that they did